[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش ملفنا الثالث
عشرون عاما على حرب العراق وعلى اسقاط
صدام حسين ونهايه نظامه الذي حكم العراق
على مدى 30 عاما واليوم وبعد مرور 20 عاما
على الحرب لا يزال العراق يواجه خلافا
مستمرا على هويه الدوله والنظام وفق تقرير
لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط فان الاشكاليه التي
لا تزال قائمه هي عدم حسم هويه النظام
وهويه الدوله معا فالعراق الدوله لا يزال
يعاني اختلالا على صعيد تحديد توصيفها بما
يجعلها اسيره لرؤى القوه والاحزاب
السياسيه التي بدا بعضها يتغول كثيرا في
كل مفاصل الدوله وعلى صعيد النظام السياسي
فانه بسبب المحاصصه العرقيه والطائفيه
التي لم تتمكن القوى السياسيه من التخلص
منها فان الدوله لا تزال مساعيها خجوله
على صعيد ممارسه الحكم فالعراق مثلا لم
يحسم بعد اي نظام يمكن ان يصلح له في ظل
دستور تم تصفيته عليها عام 2005 ومن الصعب
تغييره
كيف سقط نظام صدام حسين في العشرين من
مارس 2003 بدات الحرب التي اطلق عليها
الامريكيون عمليه حريه العراق نشر نحو 150
الف جندي امريكي واربعين الف جنديين
بريطاني في العراق
سماء بغداد تحولت الى كره نار ضخمه بعد
عمليات القصف الامريكي البريطانيه
اصبحت الحرب حربا جويه بامتياز وصلت
غاراتها الى القصر الرئاسي
الخامس والعشرون من مارس عبر 4000 جندي من
المارينز مدينه الناصريه
الحادي والثلاثون من مارس معركه بريه وقعت
بين العسكريين الامريكيين مع وحدات من
الحرس الجمهوري العراقي
الرابع من ابريل استولى الامريكيون على
مطار بغداد بعد معارك طاحنه مع قوات الحرس
الجمهوري
السابع من ابريل
استولى التحالف الدولي على ثلاثه قصور
رئاسيه في بغداد
التاسع من ابريل 2003 انهار النظام
العراقي وسيطر الامريكيون على العاصمه
بغداد
انتزعت تمثال صدام حسين بدبابات امريكيه
من قاعدته
الاول من مايو 2003 اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
نهايه المعارك ومواصله الحرب ضد الارهاب
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من عمان مهدي
جاسم الباحث في شان العراقي اهلا بك من
بغداد حمزه مصطفى المحلل السياسي اهلا بكم
ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من عمان
معك استاذ مهدي استاذ مهدي عشرون عاما منذ
الاطاحه بنظام صدام حسين
اعوام ما الذي قدمته للعراق هل فعلا تم
التاسيس الحقيقي للديمقراطيه العراقيه ام
على عكس ذلك بان الوضع الى الاسوا
بدايه مساء الخير ستريم لشخصك ولجمهورك
ولضيفك الكريم من بغداد يعني ما زال
العراقيون لم يحسموا حتى المجتمع الدولي
وحتى الاعلام ايضا يحسم العناوين التي يتم
التعامل معها هل هي ذكرى هل هي نكبه هل هي
احتلال هل هي غزو هل هي تحرير حتى هذه
المفردات والعناوين لم يتم حسمها بعد
وبالتالي تخضع
لمتقلبات العامل القوي والعامل الصعب في
التعامل مع هذا الحدث الذي يشترك فيه قد
يكون الجميع هذا التحول في الشرق الاوسط
وفي المنطقه وفي
العالم ايضا من الصعوبه ان نختزله في
عنوانين لكن هناك نتائج وهناك افرازات
وهناك مفاهيم اذا ذهبنا واذا تحدثنا فقط
لنذهب الى النتيجه مباشره افهم واتفهم جدا
بانه لا يمكن اختزال كل التعقيدات التي
يعيشها الملف العراقي في منهجين ولكن
الاكيد بانه 20 سنه قادره ان نفهم منها اي
التوجهات سائر فيه العراق ايجابي ام سلبي
النتيجه بحسب قراءتك ما هي
بكل تاكيد حتى يعني نفرز الدوله عن
الديمقراطيه الدوله من قبل
2003 وفي فتره التسعينات يجب ان نكون
منصفين لا توجد لا توجد دوله دوله حقيقيه
بسبب الحصار الذي فرض عنوان موجود نعم
للدوله لكن مؤسسات الدوله الفساد كثير من
غياب القانون في بعض الاحيان هنا ركائز
الدوله وهيبه الدوله هنا بدات انه تكون
ركيكه ومهلهله جاءت بعد 2003 هنا المؤسسه
نعم خليني التقط منك هذه النقطه وانقلها
لضيف الاستاذ حمزه استاذ حمزه هل تتفق
بانه 20 سنه راينا فيها مؤسسات مهلهله
مؤسسات غير مؤسسه لدوله يمكن ان
تطمح يوما ما او ان كانت فعلا تؤسسها الان
للديمقراطيه حقيقيه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
للمشاهدين الكرام نعم الاشكاليه الحقيقيه
التي نعانيها منذ عشرين سنه الى اليوم
تعود الى بدايات التاسيس بمعنى الى اسقاط
النظام السابق كهدف مشترك بين الامريكان
وبين قوى المعارضه العراقيه كل الطرفين
الامريكان وقوى المعارضه العراقيه لم لم
توجد لديهما استراتيجيه لما بعد السقوط
يعني الامريكان اسقطوا صدام حسين وانتزعوا
تمثال يوم 9 نيسان لكن لم تكن لديهم رؤيه
يوم عشره نيسان وقوى المعارضه العراقيه
مشتثه بالاساس منذ البدايه وعندما استولت
على السلطه لم يكن امامها سوى ان تتعامل
مع مع السلطه بوصفها غنيمه فتاسست
المحافظه العرقيه والطائفيه التي يعاني
منها الجميع لكن تقريبا معظم السياسي
صحيح ولكن استاذ حمزه هناك كذلك يطرح سؤال
سيقول لك بعضهم بانه المرحله الاولى التي
قلت بانه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم
تؤسس
يمكن ان تتحملها واشنطن ولكن المحاصصه
فيما بعد سيتحملها العراقيون نحن لا نتحدث
عن سنتين ثلاثه اربعه خمسه نتحدث عن 20
سنه
نعم ولذلك هذه انا قلت لك هذه الاشكاليه
قام منذ ذلك التاريخ الى اليوم لم تستطع
القوى السياسيه العراقيه من التخلص من
المحاصصه جرت محاوله عام العام الماضي
عندما جرت انتخابات اواخر عام 2021 وفاز
فيها التيار الصدري بالاغلبيه وشكل تحالف
ثلاثي مع الكرد مع جزء من جزء من السنه من
اجل ان يشكل حكومه اغلبيه وطنيه تقضي على
المحاصه باعتبار نبدا المرحله الحقيقيه من
مفاهيم الديمقراطيه وهي الموالاه
والمعارضه لكن هذا لم يتحقق بسبب الثلث
المعطل الفلفل المعطل كما بدا الديمقراطي
موجود في كل دول العالم ولكن نحن
ديموقراطيتنا شكليه لدينا ديمقراطيه نجري
انتخابات كل اربع سنوات نغير رئيس الوزراء
كل اربع سنوات لا احد يتشبث بالسلطه لكن
هذه الديمقراطيه بحد ذاتها لديها اشكاليات
كثيره والاهم من ذلك انه لم توجد اجراءات
حقيقيه لترسيخ قيم الدوله بمعنى ليست
الديمقراطيه هي فقط الهدفيه وسيله لتحقيق
جمله اهداف ولكن الدوله هي التي تعاني هذا
الخلل في مؤسساتها وهو الذي يقول كل
سياسين عراقيين يعترفون جميعا ان لدينا
خلل في هذا الموضوع واننا لم نستطع حتى
الان من بناء دوله قادره على ان يعني ممكن
تختزل المراحل عشرين سنه كثيره
دوله على الاقل
تتحدث عن خلل استاذ مهدي من يتحمل مسؤوليه
هذا الخلل خاصه اننا نتحدث عن فتره طويله
وعطفا على كلام ضيفي منذ قليل وانقل لك
كذلك ما يقوله بعض العراقيين وقراناه في
الواقع في بعض التعليقات البعض يقول بانه
في فتره صدام كانت الامور احسن الى اين
هكذا التعليقات اكيد بان حضرتك قراتها الى
اي مدى هذه التعليقات دقيقه ام هي تعليقات
تبين بعض الاحباط الذي يعيشه العراقيون
من الصعب ان يوضع العراقيون بين خيارين
بين ديكتاتوريه سابقه وبين ديموقراطيه
فوضويه حاليا نعم في النظام السابق هناك
دوله هناك
قوات امنيه هناك قانون بعض الشيء يوجد
نظام نظام قائم موجود لا توجد مثل ما حاصل
الان فوضى في اداره الدوله لا يوجد فساد
حتى وان كانت هناك نسبه معينه من الفساد
بعد يعني حقبه التسعينات لكن من يشترك
الجميع يشترك بما فيهم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي لم تضع خارطه الطريق ما
بعد اسقاط النظام عندما هدت جميع المؤسسات
القوات الامنيه وزاره وزاره الاعلام وزاره
الثقافه بقيه الوزارات الاخرى وبالتالي
هذا هذا التفكك بني عليه
نتائج الان نراها ونلمسها الاحزاب التي
جاءت في للسلطه هذه النخبه لم تكن قادره
على بناء دوله لم تؤمن ايضا بدمقراطيه
التحول الجديد ايضا في شارع العراقي يتحمل
مسؤوليه كبيره وبالتالي ما نراها اليوم هو
وهم ديمقراطيه وليست هناك ديمقراطيه ما
معنى الديمقراطيه ونحن نتصدر اليوم قوائم
الفساد ما معنى الديمقراطيه اليوم وهناك
عاطلين عن العمل جيوش من البطاله جيوش من
الاميه ما معنى الديمقراطيه وهناك
المخدرات اليوم تضرب اطناب المجتمع
العراقي ما معنى الديمقراطيه وهناك
ميليشيات وهناك سلاح منفرد ما معنى
الديمقراطيه وهناك محاصصه ومغانم ما معنى
الديمقراطيه وهناك لا توجد هيبه وسياده
للدوله حضرتك لا يلغي فقط الديمقراطيه لما
تتحدث عن ملفات الفساد عن الميليشيات عن
السلاح المنفلات هذا كذلك يضرب في صمم
الدوله وكانك تقول ليس هناك دوله مكتمله
بالمعنى التقليدي التي تعرف به الدول
بكل تاكيد لا توجد لدينا دوله والجميع
يعلم والجميع يعترف بذلك نحن امام نسب
عاليه نسب مخيفه من اهتزاز ثقه الشارع
بالنخب السياسيه لا توجد انتخابات حره
وشفافه اليوم هناك صراع على قانون
الانتخابات الذي يفصل بمزاجات وقياسات
الاحزاب قبل قبل يومين سقوط مروحيه
تحمل عناوين
خارجه عن يعني مفهوم سيطره الدوله على على
سيادتها وعلى اجوائها عائده او عائده الى
الى قصد مفهوم المخدرات مفهوم ضبط القانون
واحترام القانون هيبه الدوله وسيطره
الدوله على الشارع ولا اذا نحن امام وهم
للديمقراطيه
سوقتها الاحزاب بطريقه معينه لظروف معينه
نتيجه ظرف ما
ارتكب
بزمن
بظروف بمسببات مغلوطه لحد هذه اللحظه
اليوم تتحملها الولايات المتحده
استاذ حمزه ما رايك وكان موضوعنا ليست
ديمقراطيه وانما هل هناك دوله حقيقيه في
العراق او هل تمكن العراق من التاسيس
لدوله حقيقيه صله 20 سنه هذا السؤال
نعم هو الاشكاليه وين ستريم انه عندما
النظام السابق وصل الى السلطه عام 68 وورث
دوله تاسست عام 1921 فهناك دوله لكن عام
2003 المتحده تعمدت اسقاط الدوله وليس
النظام النظام ليست دوله وليس العراق نظام
سياسي ممكن يسقط وياتي نظام اخر بديل الى
سواء كان بطريقه ديمقراطيه او بطريقه
التنصيب او كذا لكن اللي حصل انهارت
مؤسسات الدوله البديل الذي حصل هو فقط
بديل ديمقراطي صحيح للديمقراطيه العراقيه
ناشئه وهناك يعني لا نستطيع ان نبخس حق
هذا الموضوع هناك تطور في مفهوم
الديمقراطيه بدليل كما قلت لك انتخابات
تجرى بصرف النظر عن نسبه المشاركه
التداول السلمي للسلطه موجود ولكن
الاشكاليه اشكاليه الدوله وهويه النظام
السياسي هل هو نحن لحد الان نناقش في
العراق هل مثلا
نعود الى النظام الرئاسي ام نبقى نظام
برلماني ولكن
الحد حتى الان مفهوم الدوله بمعنى فصلها
عن عن
وقتا طويل فهناك هناك
نعم الم ياخذ وقتا طويل هذا النقاش بخصوص
مفهوم النظام او اختيار النظام
يعني ممكن نقول انه ياخذ وقت طويل ولا
يزال يجرى يعني هذا النقاش هناك الكثير من
الاراء تطرح بجراه في وسائل الاعلام
العراقيه وهناكم مؤتمرات تعقد هناك
تظاهرات ضد النظام السياسي بمعنى انه
عندما ظهرت تظاهرات 2019 رفعت شعار نريد
وطن وهذا الشعار رفعه مواطنون شبان صغار
يريدون وطنا والسبب في ذلك انه انه يعانون
هؤلاء الكثير من هؤلاء الشبان عندما سقط
النظام 2003 ربما لم يكن قد ولدوا بعد
وبالتالي لا يعرفون شيء عن الحقبه السابقه
وانما يريدون وطن حقيقي هذه الاشكاليات
موجوده ولكنها متى تنضج هذا هو السؤال
الذي
يواجهون هو في كل حالات هذا السؤال واسئله
اخرى قابله لان تطرح في حلقات اخرى ان شاء
الله بالازدهار دائما العراق في قادم
الشكر من عمان مهدي جاسم الباح ث في الشان
العراقي ومن بغداد حمزه مصطفى المحلله
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لكم
ناتي الى نهايه بانوراما لهذا المساج شكرا
على طب المتابعه والسلام عليكم